[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit
Barbara halweg guten Abend schön dass
Sie dabei sind wie auch Norbert Lehmann
mit viel Fußball ja schönen guten Abend
von mir hochrangiger Besuch kam heute in
die Ukraine
[Musik]
Nato-Generalsekretär Stoltenberg
überraschend in Kiew dabei geht es auch
um den möglichen NATO-Beitritt der
Ukraine
Baustelle Bundeswehr wir müssen besser
werden sagt Verteidigungsminister
Pistorius und will die Führung der
Truppe neu aufstellen
Ende eines testflugs die riesenrakete
Starship hebt erfolgreich ab explodiert
aber Minuten später
[Musik]
nahezu alle wichtigen westlichen
Unterstützer der Ukraine waren nach
Kriegsausbruch schon in Kiew nur einer
noch nicht
nato-generalsekretärs deutenberg mit
seinem Besuch heute setzt er klare
Zeichen der Platz der Ukraine ist in der
NATO sagt Stolberg auch Richtung kremme
der gibt als Kriegsziel an genau das
verhindern zu wollen Lena sünderbuch
der höchste Repräsentant der NATO
betritt ukrainischen Boden das erste Mal
seit Kriegsbeginn der Chef des
Militärbündnisses im Zentrum Kiel
Präsident selensky versichert er die
NATO stehe der Ukraine so lange wie
nötig zur Seite
lassen Sie es mich deutlich sagen der
rechtmäßige Platz der Ukraine ist in der
euro-atlantischen Familie der
NATO und mit der Zeit wird unsere
Unterstützung Ihnen helfen das zu
ermöglichen
bislang hat die NATO selbst die Ukraine
nur etwa mit Uniformen oder
medizinischen Gütern unterstützt Waffen
liefern nur einzelne Mitgliedsstaaten
die Reaktion des Kreml auf den Besuchs
sollten Bergs folgt prompt Russland
bekräftigt sein Kriegsziel eine Aufnahme
des Nachbarlandes in die NATO zu
verhindern
andernfalls wäre das eine ernsthafte
erhebliche Bedrohung für die Sicherheit
unseres Landes
die russische Führung stellt den Krieg
längst auch als einen Konflikt mit dem
Westen insgesamt dar und versucht mit
allen Mitteln mehr Männer für den
Fronteinsatz zu gewinnen die USA
kündigen jetzt weitere Militärhilfe für
die Ukraine an Dänemark und die
Niederlande sagen 14 Leopard 2 Panzer zu
und in Kiew spricht Nato-Generalsekretär
Stoltenberg persönlich eine Einladung
aus die Ukraine soll beim nächsten
NATO-Gipfel im Juli mit am Tisch sitzen
ihr Beitritt ganz oben auf der Agenda
stehen
fragen wir Florian neuhahn in Brüssel
warum dieser Besuch jetzt
bei der Nato-Generalsekretär will
offenbar bewusst einen deutliches Signal
aussenden einen Kriegsjahr lang hat auf
einen solchen Besuch verzichtet weil die
NATO als Allianz eben nicht in diesen
Krieg hineingezogen werden will und
deshalb stand auch ein NATO-Beitritt der
Ukraine nie auf der Tagesordnung als der
ukrainische Präsident selenski vor einem
halben Jahr im Herbst letzten Jahres
öffentlich noch einmal einen Antrag
stellt auf NATO-Beitritt seines Landes
da kann das vielen vor allem in
Westeuropa gar nicht gelegen das sei
hieß es damals bestenfalls ein Thema für
die ferne Zukunft jetzt kann man hier
schon ein wirklich deutlichen Wandel in
der Kommunikation feststellen denn
erstmals macht eben der
Nato-Generalsekretär deutlich dass
dieser NATO-Beitritt jetzt top Thema des
nächsten NATO-Gipfels im Sommer im
Julius sein wird das heißt nicht dass
man dann etwa den Beitritt der Ukraine
beschließen wird aber man wird ja etwas
anbieten müssen als NATO das könnten
etwa irgendwelche Formen von
Sicherheitsgarantien sein für die Zeit
bis dahin aufnehmen kann die NATO die
Ukraine erst dann wenn dieser Krieg
einmal zu Ende ist danke schön für diese
Einschätzung aus Brüssel Florian
der ukrainische
fotografiegenioletka hält den Krieg in
Bildern fest eins davon wurde jetzt zum
weltpressefoto des Jahres gekürt es
zeigt die hochschwangere Irina kalinina
vier Männer tragen sie aus einer
zerstörten Klinik in mariopol ihr Baby
wird tot zur Welt gebracht eine halbe
Stunde später stirbt auch die Mutter das
Bild so die Jury symbolisiert den
Schrecken des Krieges für die
Zivilbevölkerung
die Unterstützung für die Ukraine
fortsetzen und die Bundeswehr
kampfbereit und einsatzfähig machen das
sind zwei der wichtigsten Ziele von
Verteidigungsminister Pistorius dafür
will er Strukturen in seinem Ministerium
und bei den Streitkräften verändern auch
das
Führungspersonals berichtet
Panzer Hubschrauber Flugzeuge zu oft
dauert es zu lange bis sie fahren oder
fliegen zu oft werden sie zu teuer ein
Grund die komplizierten Strukturen des
Verteidigungsministeriums ein Geflecht
aus leitungsbüros Stäben Abteilungen mit
eigentlichen Leben sein Haus will der
neue Minister nun straffen um die
Prozesse zu beschleunigen der hat viele
Organigramme gesehen und selber auch an
ihnen gearbeitet als ich dies sah war
mir relativ schnell klar dass so man ein
so riesen Haus nicht führen kann schon
gar nicht effizient die Büros der
zivilen Staatssekretäre so Pistorius
heute in einer Personalversammlung
sollen ausgedünnt werden dafür soll ein
Planungs- und Führungsstab wieder
eingerichtet werden mit General
freudigen an der Spitze des landleiter
des Ukraine Krisenstabes Kritik von den
zivilen Beschäftigten der Bundeswehr die
einen Macht zu Wachs der Generäle
abwöhnisch beugen ihre Sorge dass der
Minister künftig Vorlagen nur durch
einen militärischen Filter erhält was
wir nicht brauchen ist eine zusätzliche
militärische Führung des Ministeriums
das ist die vornehmeraufgabe der zivilen
Staatssekretäre den bisherigen
Generalinspektor tauschte Pistorius
bereits aus genau wie die Leiterin des
beschaffungsamts ein Minister der es
ernst meint das gefällt nicht allen es
rumort im Ministerium Unterstützung
dagegen aus Ampel und Opposition einer
Reform überfällig das ist über ein Jahr
liegen geblieben und wenn er insofern
jetzt an die Struktur des Ministeriums
herangeht und für Schnelligkeit sorgt
dann ist das in Zeiten der Zeitenwende
gut und richtig die muss auch bei der
Bundeswehr vor allen Dingen bei den
Offizieren im Verteidigungsministerium
ankommen zu glauben der Minister kommt
und geht wir bleiben ich glaube das
sollte sich jeder jetzt mal Abschminken
auch im Bundestag verteidigt Pistorius
heute seine Reformideen er weiß es ist
ein langer Weg bis sie tatsächlich
greifen werden
[Musik]
[Applaus]
einen Plan B brauchen derzeit Bahn und
Flugreisende wegen verschiedenster
Streiks an mehreren deutschen Flughäfen
legt das Sicherheitspersonal für zwei
Tage die Arbeit nieder wie hier in
Hamburg sind bis Samstag alle Abflüge
gestrichen betroffen sind auch die
Flughäfen in Düsseldorf und Köln-Bonn
morgen kommt noch Stuttgart dazu auch
bei der Bahn wird gestreikt von 3 Uhr
nachts bis mindestens morgen 13 Uhr
fahren keine Fernzüge und auch der
Nahverkehr fällt weitgehend aus
der Wohnungsneubau in Deutschland steht
vor dem Kollaps das sagen die großen
bauverbände als Gründe nennen sie die
immer weiter steigenden Kosten nicht nur
die Zahl der Baugenehmigungen gehe
zurück auch bei 40 Prozent der bereits
genehmigten Projekte habe der Rohbau
noch nicht begonnen die Verbände fordern
Bund und Länder dazu auf die
Fördergelder für den Wohnungsbau
deutlich aufzustocken
um Deutschland mit genug Energie zu
versorgen soll jetzt auch auf Rügen ein
Terminal für flüssig Erdgas entstehen
das halten viele für völlig falsch und
überflüssig heute stellten sich vor Ort
Kanzler Scholz und Wirtschaftsminister
Harbeck der Kritik
bislang sind in Deutschland drei
lng-anlagen am Netz in Wilhelmshaven
Brunsbüttel und lubimini drei weitere
sind geplant ein zweites in
Wilhelmshaven eines in Stade und ein
zweites in Lubmin ob die Besucher aus
Berlin die Wogen auf Rügen glätten
konnten berichtet Bernd Mosebach
für viele hier in Binz ist der Besuch
des Kanzlers längst überfällig die
lng-pläne der Bundesregierung stoßen
seit zwei Monaten auf breiten Widerstand
auf Deutschlands größter Insel
geil ist weil wir damit unserer Natur
nichts Gutes tun wir machen unsere
eigene Heimat kaputt unseren Lebensraum
kaputt und das ist nicht das was wir
wollen weil ich vom Tourismus lebe und
durchaus befürchte dass auch das LNG
Terminal hier vor Ort negativer
Einflüsse auf den Tourismus haben wird
ein möglicher offshore-standort für ein
lng-terminal liegt nordöstlich der Insel
das Flüssiggas würde durch eine neue
Pipeline nach Lubin gepumpt das an das
europäische Gasnetz angeschlossen ist
zweite Variante der Hafen von Mukran
eine Pipeline müsste auch in diesem Fall
gebaut werden die Röhren dafür liegen
bereits in Vokalen Restbestände aus dem
Nord Stream 2 Projekt gekauft vom Bund
die Landesregierung bezweifelt das
weitere lng-kapazitäten überhaupt
gebraucht werden will sich aber auch
nicht verweigern wenn diese Frage mit ja
beantwortet wird
haben wir immer gesagt wir stehen zu
unserer Verantwortung in
Mecklenburg-Vorpommern für die
Energieversorgung in ganz Deutschland
und ja dann werden wir auch über
verschiedene Möglichkeiten von Terminals
dann konkret reden in Binz warten die
Demonstranten auf ein Ergebnis des
Kanzler Gesprächs mit den Vertretern der
Insel und der Landespolitik alle Signale
deuten bisher darauf hin dass der Bund
an seinen kleinen festhält ein weiteres
LG Terminal im Nordosten wird wohl
gebaut werden
Menschen mit Behinderungen sollen mehr
Chancen erhalten einen Job auch
außerhalb von Werkstätten zu bekommen
ein entsprechendes Gesetz hat nun der
Bundestag beschlossen um das Ziel zu
erreichen soll unter anderem die
Ausgleichsabgabe erhöht werden sie wird
für Betriebe fällig die die Quote nicht
erfüllen Firmen mit mehr als 60
Arbeitsplätzen müssen mindestens 5%
ihrer Jobs für Menschen mit
Behinderungen bereitstellen
immer mehr Daten untermauern die Dynamik
des Klimawandels gerade in Europa der
vergangene Sommer war der heißeste und
trockenste auf unserem Kontinent seit
Beginn der Aufzeichnungen das zeigen
neue Daten der EU vom Klima
beobachtungsdienst Kopernikus er meldet
auch dass das Gletschereis so stark
schmilzt wie nie zuvor in Araber hat
sich den Bericht genauer angeschaut
immer noch sinkt der Pegelstand des
Gardasees seit fast einem Jahr kaum
Regen
2022 das wärmste und trockenste Jahr in
Europa seit Beginn der
Wetteraufzeichnungen wirkt nach
die letzten acht Jahre waren die
wärmsten acht Jahre die je gemessen
wurden das ist bemerkenswert und ein
Zeichen dafür wie sehr sich unser Klima
verändert
Hitze und Trockenheit sorgten auch für
Rekorde an den Flüssen minusrekorde
besonders im August waren die
Pegelstände von Europas Flüssen
außergewöhnlich niedrig eine weitere
Besonderheit die der Klimawandel mit
sich bringt die Wetterlage bleiben
länger stabil die
Windsysteme in den höheren Luftschichten
die verändern sich und das ist schon
seit Jahren festzustellen und wenn sich
gleichzeitig dann hoch festsetzen dann
wird es recht trocken oder wenn es dann
regnet dann kommt es kurz und heftig
runter und nicht über längere Zeit so
wie es früher der Fall war
den Hitzerekord verzeichnete auch die
sonst kälteste Region Europas Grönland
im September war es dort bis zu 8 Grad
wärmer als im Durchschnitt der
vergangenen Jahre
wir sehen an den Daten dass die extremen
Temperaturen im Zusammenhang mit dem
Ausstoß von Treibhausgasen stehen der
einzige Weg um die Tendenz zu verändern
ist es die Emissionen zu reduzieren
der kopernikusbericht will ein
wissenschaftlicher Weckruf sein auch
dafür dass Europa sich an die Folgen des
Klimawandels anpassen muss
das Kinderhilfswerk Unicef schlägt Alarm
immer weniger Kinder bekommen die
wichtigen Schutzimpfungen wegen der
corona-pandemie und wegen impfskepsis
nach Angaben von UNICEF wurden in den
vergangenen Jahren rund 67 Millionen
Kinder gar nicht oder nur teilweise
geimpft besonders niedrig ist die
Impfquote in Afrika aus Kenia berichtet
zusammen von Lojewski
die Kleine flavian hat es schwer an
diesem Tag fünf Impfungen muss das drei
Monate alte Mädchen über sich ergehen
lassen darunter auch Diphtherie Tetanus
und Keuchhusten ihre Mutter glaubt fest
an die Wirkung der Impfstoffe doch die
Skepsis auch in ihrer Familie ist groß
[Musik]
viele die Angst haben zum Beispiel meine
Schwester seid ihr Kind geboren wurde
hat sie es noch nie zur Impfung gebracht
das Impfen ist in der kleinen Klinik in
einem Slum von Nairobi kostenlos und
trotzdem wollen viele Eltern nicht
kommen
meine Freunde sagen dass die Impfung
unfruchtbar macht und damit die
Bevölkerung reduziert deshalb haben sie
Angst
auch die Pandemie hat in Kenia zu
Impfmüdigkeit geführt viele trauten sich
wegen der Ansteckungsgefahr nicht mehr
in die Klinik und ließen so auch
regelimpfungen aus wir haben uns eine
Strategie überlegt und besuchen die
Leute jetzt zu Hause dort impfen wir sie
so sind wir vorgegangen es hilft aber
trotzdem sind die Zahlen noch nicht da
wo sie vorkommen waren
logistische Herausforderungen die
Impfstoffe müssen auch in abgelegene
gegen den Afrikas gebracht werden für
die Kühlung müssen zuerst
solarbetriebene kühl Schränke
installiert werden
UNICEF fürchtet größere
Krankheitsausbrüche
viele Kinder gibt die nicht immunisiert
sind gibt es ein großes Risiko eines
Ausbruchs zum Beispiel Masern wenn es
einen Ausbruch von Masern gibt dann ist
es erwartbar das Kinder sterben
die Impfquote ist aus dem niedrigsten
Stand seit 2008 und das könnte gerade in
Afrika verheerende Folgen haben
im Jemen starben bei einer Massenpanik
mindestens 78 Menschen viele wurden
verletzt unter den Todesopfern sind nach
Angaben der hutwierebellen Frauen und
Kinder zu dem massengedränge kam es als
Händler in der Hauptstadt Sanaa
Geldspenden an Bedürftige verteilten wie
es zum Ende des Fastenmonats Ramadan
üblich ist dabei brach Panik aus
von Texas aus einmal in den Orbit und
wieder zurück in rund 90 Minuten das war
der Plan heute doch nach wenigen Minuten
explodierte die größte und
leistungsstärkste Rakete aller Zeiten
diese
riesenrakete Starship ist 120 m lang und
in der Raumfähre können künftig mal 100
Passagiere Platz finden damit will
Multimilliardär Elon Musk mal Menschen
zum Mond und Mars fliegen Claudia Bates
hat mehr
die Rakete taumelt eigentlich sollte
sich jetzt die Raumfähre von der Träger
Rakete Lösen der Jubel bei SpaceX
schlägt um
nach knapp vier Minuten explodiert
Starship in einer Höhe von 29 Kilometern
mask wirkt dennoch nicht allzu
enttäuscht kurz zuvor 33 Triebwerke
schieben die gigantische Rakete nach
oben der Start ist geglückt und allein
das schon ist für die Raumfahrt ein
Erfolg
so arbeitet SpaceX sie machen und machen
bis es irgendwann funktioniert sie sind
gut durch den Staat gekommen mit dieser
riesigen monsterrakete das ist schon
eine Errungenschaft es ist noch ein
weiter Weg aber das ist ein guter Anfang
die Rakete besteht aus zwei Stufen der
weiße ist super heavy Booster Antrieb
und oben das riesige Starship 50 m hoch
mit Platz für eine Besatzung und für
mehr als 100 Tonnen Fracht eins soll die
Raumfähre Menschen auf den Mond und den
Mars bringen
Starship soll im All betankt werden und
die erste orbitalrakete seien die landen
und wiederverwendet werden kann es soll
die Raumfahrt revolutionieren es ist
eine neue Vision eine Art
interplanetarisches taxi-system das ist
eine völlig neuartige Rakete nicht nur
für den Mond oder den Mars sondern
Jupiter und Saturn ein neues Kapitel in
der Geschichte der Weltraumforschung
Starship ist gespickt mit seinen suchen
die Daten werden Aufschluss darüber
geben woran der Testflug gescheitert ist
und so können schon in einigen Monaten
Raumfahrt Fans hier den nächsten Staat
Versuch bestaunen
tja auch ein neues Kapitel in der
Fußball Champions League Norbert die
Bayern sind schon raus mit dem Wunder
von München gestern Abend nicht mehr als
annähernd die Bayern wie schon in den
letzten Wochen weit weit weg entfernt
von ihrer Top-Form am Ende nur ein
mageres eins zu eins Manchester City im
Halbfinale München in der Krise
gelb rot für Bayern Trainer Tuchel kurz
vor Schluss die City Führung durch
Erling Holland kurz nach der Pause den
Münster fehlt wieder mal entscheidendes
du brauchst ganz ganz sicher die
100%igen Chancen die muss auf jeden Fall
reinmachen auf diesem Niveau sonst kann
sie in der Summe dazu führen dass so ein
Ergebnis erklärst dass eigentlich so
über 180 Minuten nicht gerechtfertigt
ist Chancen wie hier mit Leroy sané
haben sie wie schon im Hinspiel doch
auch ein verschossener Holland Elfer in
der ersten Hälfte hilft nicht weiter
mehr als der Elfmeter Ausgleich durch
Josua Kimmich ist nicht drin den Bayern
bleibt nur noch ein Titel übrig
Deutscher Meister können Sie noch werden
ja die letzte deutsche Mannschaft in
einem europäischen Pokalwettbewerb ist
jetzt Leverkusen die Bayer 11 trifft
heute Abend in der Europa liegt bei San
Luas an gegen den belgischen
Tabellenzweiten gab es Viertelfinalspiel
eins zu eins und entschieden
der Leverkusener Empfang in Belgien
wurde von der Sonne begleitet die
Stimmung voller Zuversicht auch wenn das
0:0 am Sonntag in Wolfsburg nach zuvor
fünf Siegen in Folge einen kleinen
Rückschlag darstellte geschuldet auch
der mangelnden Chancenverwertung die man
sich heute besser nicht leisten sollte
wir haben die Motivation die Hunger die
Wunsch zu spielen und eine gute zu haben
Union Berlin hat hier mit 0:3 verloren
für Fabi alonso ist das aber längst noch
kein Grund gegen die Berg ja allzu früh
das Handtuch zu werden
erste Spiel und gleich die erste
Niederlage für Alexander es wäre beim
ATP-Turnier in München der Olympiasieger
war mit einem Freilos ins Achtelfinale
gelangt und verlor dort gegen den
Australier Christopher Conne glatt in
zwei Sätzen damit sind alle deutschen
Tennisprofis im Einzel ausgeschrieben ja
und ausgerechnet das heute als wäre es
26 Geburtstag
könnte man jetzt sagen morgen ist das
Wetter ungerecht verteilt mehr dazu
gleich von östantin 9:45 Uhr begrüßt Sie
Marietta Slomka im heute-journal hier
übernimmt morgen mit Siri danke für Ihr
Interesse einen schönen Abend ihnen noch
und auf Wald
[Musik]
schönen guten Abend und herzlich
willkommen zum Wetter eindrucksvoll
dreht sich das Höhentief über
Deutschland ein und schiebt sich auch
allmählich weiter nach Westen dazu gibt
es recht kräftigen Regen und zwar von
Westen bis Richtung Alpenrand in der
Nacht sonst in den östlichen
Landesteilen da wird es sternenklar und
die Temperaturen gehen zurück im
Südwesten auf 0 Grad am Niederrhein auf
9 Grad das wäre die Temperaturspanne der
nachts morgen dann im Norden
Deutschlands und nach Osten denn viel
Sonnenschein im Südwesten brodelt es
aber im Tagesverlauf und hier bilden
sich Schauer und auch Gewitter bei
höchsten Temperaturen von 20 Grad im
Nordwesten und 14 Grad an der Ostsee
aber häufig liegen die Temperaturen um
die 15 Grad Marke und teils darüber
schauen wir auf die nächsten Tage und am
Samstag es ist in der Osthälfte häufig
sonnig im Westen bilden sich Schauer und
Gewittern 15 bis 21 Grad die Höchstwerte
ab Sonntag wird es durchwachsener mit
weiteren Schauern und Gewittern und auch
der Montag ist noch durchwachsen und
damit wünsche ich Ihnen einen schönen
Abend